Steve Bannon is now going after me on his
program. Let me give you the back story about
this. We did a segment a couple of weeks ago,
I guess it was about an actual crazy person,
as I described her going on Steve Bannon's program
and talking about all of the horrible things that
the Satanic Temple is doing. Now, as I've talked
to you before, the Satanic Temple is not a scary
organization. The Satanic Temple is no less valid
than any other religion, first and foremost. And
it turns out that the person fearmongering about
the Satanic Temple on Steve Bannon's show was
actually a sister, Mary Beth Bannon. And Steve
Bannon seems to be increasingly obsessed with
the Satanic Temple stuff. But he now has gone
after me. So here's the start of a clip from I
guess this was three days ago on his show.
He interviews some guy about the Satanic
Temple stuff. And then you'll see that they cut
to my segment about this. Okay, here's just a
few seconds. Isn't the issue got these parents
and it just takes a couple of kids because the
way they're selling that we played the jingles
on and showed the videos on Saturday. I think
my sister was here. She she brought up because a
lot of people she knows worried about this. Right.
They make it into self-empowerment. Okay. So that
segment in which he brought his sister on is the
segment that we critiqued. So then as you can see,
he actually plays my segment and we're going to go
to the end of it. You already seen my segment and
it's available. I don't think we actually need to
play the whole thing, but here's the end of it.
And then it goes into Bannon attacking me. Take
a look. Cleared that there are certain things.
That it's not just a difference of opinion. It's
not It's it's something much more pernicious and
more than that. Okay. We have more words and we're
going to. That's. That's brother. That's Brother
Dave Pacman. He's got a show. True. That's his
analysis. And we're doing this as a as a teaching
exercise. Many of you remember that interview
from a couple of weeks ago. But we also played
the Liberty Counsel who came on afterwards
and talked. Everybody's very worried about the
Satanic temple, the real thing. It's not mental,
but you see how the left, what they want to do
immediately, they don't want addressed. They
never want to talk about what the thing is. Now,
unfortunately for Steve, we've talked about what
the thing is many times we've interviewed Lucian
Graves from the Satanic Temple at least once.
Now, I don't know if it's once or twice. It's
been a while that we've been doing interviews.
We have gone into detail about the ways in which
the Satanic Temple compares in contrast to other
religions. We've talked about the principles
of the Satanic temple. We have talked about
the thing. But Steve Bannon doesn't want you
to know that or doesn't know that himself.
We want to talk about what the issue is. They
always want to do an end around are doing a a
is something that to take your eye off the ball.
Oh, right. We're not going to fall for that. Oh.
We know that these satanic clubs and the Limerick
Council has a different. Viewpoint that made the
parents there in these school systems have. Okay.
All right. So anyway, listen, Steve Bannon is
welcome on this program quite literally any time.
I'm not super interested in talking with him about
the Satanic Temple. But I guess if that's what it
takes to get him on, I'm willing to willing to do
it. There are many other things I would like to
talk to Steve Bannon about, including his role
in bringing forward one of the most disastrous
presidencies in the history of the United States,
certainly in the last 50 years. He's welcome
on the program quite literally any time.